all right trans-college swimmer leah
thomas is speaking out in her first tv
interview now saying she did not
transition to gain a competitive
advantage but now many on the left are
trying to cancel anyone that doesn't
automatically he prays on leah thomas
now even tennis legend and i mean legend
martina navratilova she's facing
blowback after the 18-time grand slam
winner
an amazing player told the new york
times quote if i faced the male
equivalent of leah and tennis that's
biology i would have no shot and i would
have been livid here with reaction a
former olympian herself fox news
contributor caitlyn jenner along with
fox news contributor tammy bruce good to
see you both you know i saw your
comments caitlyn
you said you were right she followed the
rules as they're written problem is the
rules are not fair which you have
acknowledged on this program that's the
problem
it certainly is you know this is not
leah thomas's fault um
it's really the woke world that's out
there right now uh gave leah thomas the
ability to
honestly take away medals
from other athletes she played by the
rules but my beef has been with the ncaa
they've got to harden these rules
because the ncaa should be out to
protect women's sports you know
transitioning
i really feel like it comes with
responsibility
and integrity and i think in the good
morning america
show that she did i think there was a
lack of that
uh it was all about her and her
happiness where
you know when she was a male swimmer
just a few years ago she wasn't happy at
all now she's all of a sudden happy well
i am into happiness i am glad she is
happy but
she did it at the expense of the other
female athletes you know individual
happiness here in leah's case
um
cannot take priority over the undeniable
biological fact that she's trans and has
a massive physical advantage over the
other athletes i mean you see her on the
blocks and i can see the girl standing
next door if you look up to her she's
very tall um and and the girl's thinking
i i can't beat that you know i'm going
for second place and it shouldn't be
that way and the ncaa has to protect
women's sports
and now they want to take it to the
olympics uh tammy what's your thoughts
on it
well clearly the rules do have to change
caitlyn is absolutely right the rules
are not written with this kind of
situation in mind and i would disagree
just slightly with caitlyn she's right
it's about the woke society but whenever
the rules that we all live under seem to
be really absurdly ridiculous
it does come down to character it comes
down to the nature of who we are about
whether or not we are going to take
advantage of rules that were written and
set for something entirely different
without certain expectations and this is
when it comes down to what we've been
seeing with leah thomas and i've been
saying this for quite some time this has
nothing to do with transgenderism at
this point it is about character and
it's about selfishness it's about
self-indulgence uh it's it's about
narcissism and
caitlyn wasn't kidding when she was
talking about happiness uh leah noted
that when she competed against men
that she was miserable and she's when
she competes against women she's happier
well she's winning more she did not win
like this against men and when you talk
about the olympic sean there would be no
real chance to even compete you know at
all let alone be assigned onto the
olympic uh swimming team so this is a
remarkable examination about uh
self-indulgence and malignant narcissism
even when it comes to what you're
willing to do to others in order to get
what you want when it is inherently and
completely unfair so that's what this is
the transgender people that are out
there caitlyn a very good example of
someone who's transitioned who has
character this is about individual
attitudes this is about who we are as
people that's a good idea not about the
transgender issue at all
you know uh
caitlin we talked about this you you
drive the ball
to what 285 300 yards i'm never playing
golf with you by the way ever i don't
know i don't need to be humiliated i'll
be your caddy i'll be katelyn's caddy
though but it's all right
well maybe we'll do it cash all right
but
a lot of it uh but the point is you
wouldn't play eve
a senior event because you feel you have
that advantage we have about 30 seconds
yeah no uh i definitely do and i've been
through this whole process in fact i am
completely transitioned i don't know
what the case is in leah's case but i've
been hormones for a very long time and
can hit the ball a long way that's not a
problem here's a good example
what if the
nba
adopted the rules of the ncaa michael
jordan in his prime all of a sudden
decides i'm trans one year on hormone
replacement
therapy and he can play in the wnba how
do you think that would work out
i got a role but um i think
i think if i do play i'll bring hundreds
because it's going to cost me a fortune
anyway thank you both hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else